[Music]
the United States slowly phasing back to
normality this morning as Americans
commemorate a memorial day unlike any
other today three states are easing
those strict Cova 19 restrictions Pete
yep hair salons barbershops and massage
therapy businesses may open their doors
in Kentucky as well as Massachusetts the
state also allowing labs to reopen and
outdoor activities like hunting boating
and fishing may resume meanwhile in the
state of New York campgrounds and RV
parks are back in business on this
Memorial Day more than three hundred and
sixty-six thousand people have recovered
from the virus so far in the United
States and that is very promising
let's bring in right now try to spy from
Washington DC the Vice President of the
United States Mike Pence who is live at
the Pentagon mr. vice president good
morning to you good morning all it's
great to have you especially since
you've been heading up that corona virus
task force for a couple of months now
when you see so many of the states start
to reopen but then you see those images
of America which is clearly pandemic
fatigued and you see all these people
out on the beach or on the boardwalk and
they are shoulder-to-shoulder and I'm
sure dr. Burks would say they're too
close if they're not wearing a mask what
do those kind of images what do you make
of those giving that the whole idea is
to keep 6 feet from each other and if
you don't there could be trouble well
first let me let me say on this Memorial
Day our hearts and our prayers are with
the families of all of our fallen I'm
not far from Arlington National Cemetery
I'll be with the President and the First
Lady in just a short period of time and
this Memorial Day in the midst of this
coronavirus pandemic is particularly
grievous because you know communities
large and small generally come together
they get their arms around those gold
star families but today they'll be more
separation and more distance and I just
want them all to know that they're in
our hearts today but you know you you
just recited a lot of progress on
reopening America and I must tell you
the President and I are very confident
that as as now all 50 states have begun
the process of reopening our country
that while there may be instances where
where people are or would would do well
to be reminded about the importance of
social distancing and the importance of
continuing regular hygiene we have every
confidence that that as as these
restrictions are more loosened in the
days ahead the American people are going
to step forward and put this country
back to work in a safe and in
responsible way mr. vice president the
president tweeted about schools he said
schools in our country should be opened
ASAP much very good information now
available what's the latest on this
because we're many people in New York
City for instance are wondering should
are their kids gonna be going back to
school if not should we enroll them
somewhere else well you know it's
important to reflect today on two things
I think Ainsley number one is the the
more than 98 thousand Americans who've
lost their lives our hearts are with
their families on this Memorial Day as
well but but I think we also do well to
reflect on the fact that because the
American people embrace the president's
leadership listen to state and local
authorities that tens of thousands of
families have been spared the heartache
of that loss and we've seen real
progress all across the country
I mean hospitalizations are declining
we've seen a steady decline in cases and
new cases across the country and most
importantly fatalities continue to
decline you saw the governor of New York
as you mentioned their state say that
New York is essentially back where they
started back in March and so we are we
are on the far side
of this epidemic in in many of the
places most impacted and that's given us
an opportunity not just the issue as we
did now more than a month ago the
guidelines to open up America again but
the CDC and the task force are going to
continue to produce useful information
about about how we can bring back our
schools how we can bring back summer
camps how we can go back to churches and
synagogues and mosques and enjoy in a
safe and responsible way our freedoms of
religion so what we're working very
closely with university presidents
around the country over the last several
weeks we'll be welcoming them to the
White House soon and we have every
confidence that whether it be our
universities around the country or
whether it be a primary and secondary
education that we're in in most areas of
the country we're going to be able to
get kids back to school in a safe and
responsible way mr. vice president thank
you very much for joining us this
morning you know there is an ongoing
tension between blue state governor's
governor's that are keeping states
locked down a little bit more in the
uncertainty that that creates I've got
to ask you because the president just
put out a tweet just moments ago and it
pertains to this and we want to get your
reaction he tweeted this he said I love
the great state of North Carolina so
much so that I insisted on having the
RNC the Republican National Convention
in Charlotte at the end of August
unfortunately Democrat governor Roy
Cooper is still in shutdown mood and
unable to guarantee that by August we
will be allowed full attendance in the
arena in other words we would be
spending millions of dollars building
the arena to a very high standard
without even knowing if the Democrat
governor would allow the Republican
Party to fully occupy the space plans
are being made by many thousands of
enthusiastic Republicans and others to
head to North Carolina in August they
must be immediately given an answer by
the governor as to whether or not the
space will be allowed to be fully
occupied if not we will be reluctantly
forced to find with all the jobs and
economic development it brings another
Republican National Convention site this
is not something I want to do thank you
and I love the people of North Carolina
so this is a a macro look at something
that's happened at the smaller level as
well governor's locking down decisions
can't be made businesses being
hit first if you would to the RNC in the
convention and the possibility of
changing it and then that question
overall well it's an issue we've been
talking about Pete because these
national conventions literally take many
months to organize and prepare and and
you know there are states around the
country we think of Texas we think of
Florida Georgia the last two states I
visited last week that have made a
tremendous progress on reopening their
communities and reopening their
economies and I think the president is
is absolutely intent on ensuring that as
we see our nation continue to make
steady progress on putting the corona
virus epidemic in the past that come
this August will be able to come
together in a in a safe and responsible
venue and INRI nominate president Donald
Trump for four more years but what what
you hear the president saying today is
just a very reasonable request of the
governor of North Carolina we all want
to be in Charlotte we love North
Carolina but having a sense now is
absolutely essential because of the
immense preparations that are involved
and we look forward to working with the
governor Cooper getting a swift response
and and if needs be if needs be moving
the national convention to a state that
that is farther along on reopening and
and can say with confidence that that we
can gather there mr. vice president
earlier in today's program we talked to
a couple of guys who owned a diner in
Pennsylvania York Pennsylvania and they
reopened on Mother's Day weekend despite
the the fact that the governor kept the
state closed down they defied the order
they appeared on our program I think
about four days ago and within just a
few hours then the state suspended their
license and said you got to close they
are still open this morning we talked to
them listen to what they had to say
earlier
governor wolf through a little
tyrannical temper tantrum
and decided to just you know suspend our
is it through emergency powers to
suspend our licenses but it's not about
a diner it's about the American people
they want the freedom every customer
comes in they thank us thank you being
open
we provide something that the community
needs right now to flatten this fear and
progress forward flatten the fear mr.
vice president can you understand the
frustration with certain business owners
in certain locations that have not
reopened yet well I really can't Steven
it's it's the reason why even before the
the 45 days to slow the spread president
Trump had us issue guidelines to open up
America again and and we made it clear
to Governor wolf and governors across
the country that they could implement
that guidance not just on a statewide
basis but on a county-by-county basis
and this last week I actually was able
to to grab lunch in a nice diner in in
Georgia another one in Florida I think
the American people see that we we can
safely and responsibly reopen our
restaurants in many places around the
country and we're just going to continue
to urge governor wolf and other
governors around the country to look for
those opportunities not to use the
coercive power of the state but to find
ways to to literally restore the
freedoms that we all cherish this is a
freedom-loving country today we feel on
our hearts a particular weight of
gratitude to the people who fought and
died for that freedom and we're just
going to continue in all of our
interactions with governor's around the
country to encourage them to restore
their economies reopen their country and
we're working in full partnership with
governor's to make sure they have the
testing supplies and resources and PPE
necessary to be able to accomplish that
in a way that puts the health of their
citizens even right alongside the health
of a growing economy
mr. vice president we heard the airplane
flying it reminds me the airforce and
all of the branches that I know your son
is serving Pete you have served my dad
served my grandfather's Steve I know
Minnie and your family have served what
is your message on this Memorial Day by
the way I read your op-ed on foxnews.com
it's called this Memorial Day our
freedoms are cherished even more and
here is why it was beautifully written
but what's your message for our great
country thank you
well this message on this Memorial Day
even in the midst of these challenging
times is that this freedom loving nation
knows that freedom isn't free and we are
grateful every day for all of the men
and women who serve in the Army Navy Air
Force Marines and Coast Guard but
today's the day that we remember those
who served and fell in battle and when
the President and I and the first lady
and Karen gathered in just a few moments
at Arlington will lay a wreath will say
a prayer and I just encourage people
across this country to remember the
families of our fallen in your prayers
especially this day when you see people
out waving flags and standing up for
freedom across the country during these
challenging times this Memorial Day I
think we do feel a special special
weight of gratitude to those who
defended that freedom throughout our
history who paid the ultimate sacrifice
for our freedom and they are in our
hearts today they're in our prayers and
to each of them I want them to know this
Memorial Day we are grateful to them and
and their loved ones who who
demonstrated that what the Bible says is
no greater love the Lord says that no
greater love as a man than this then he
should lay down his life for his friends
and today we remember all the men and
women throughout our history who have
laid down their lives for our freedom
indeed mr. vice president thank you very
much we will see you in the president at
the tomb of the you know unknowns very
shortly at Arlington thank you very much
thank you so much